l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
momento sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo episodio di altri due prima di
cominciare vi faccio questa brevissima
premessa lunedì 8 maggio quindi questo
lunedì che arriva dalle 16 in poi farò
una live
qui sul canale di auto ast 2 dove lo
completiamo fino alla fine quindi dalle
quattro in poi di lunedì
voglio vedervi tutti sul canale che
finiamo insieme outlast 2000 shoah video
bei ragazzi ok
volevate che ci fosse già schiera
profuga gesù cristo perché essere pieno
di gente ovunque
qual è il problema premesso questo
passare di qua senza che nessuno mi cita
o qualcosa del genere
lo chiedo per cortesia non sto capendo
dove si chiama una vacca che sa dove
cazzo uscito questo da dove vai vai vai
veloce la cera verso il suo gatto ceraso
luce
apri c'era un fosso maledetto indovinate
che cosa ho preso io il fosso proprio il
fosso preciso
chiudi chiudi a gesù batteria cioè anche
per caso una benda
no non c'è neanche una benda [ __ ] cuore
datemi una benda ragazzi mi toccano ha
tolto sono morto perché non si trovano
mai le boe ministro gioco miglia sono
più peggio dell'oro e devo fermare la
ruota per andare avanti
è un meccanismo in teoria ci dovrebbe
essere dovrebbe esserci un collegamento
qualche parte giusta ok
devo togliere il flusso d'acqua
fantastico salvatore aranzulla coi suoi
tutorial può accompagnare solo ho
cercato tutt altro che il tutorial per
chiudere che cazzo arrestare un mulino
il mourinho di banderas perfetto se
giudice dovrebbe funzionare ma in teoria
grazie veloce quello veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce cav h
non passano di sì che passano tutta la
vecchia torri sempre accorre risto
giovane novità incredibile niente non so
dove andare forte eccolo perfetto mai
bailey rae una mucca non mi seguite
sucate melo tutto
meno male che non mi fate che sono le
mucche morte allora ragazzo li dobbiamo
trovare st [ __ ] miniera che non sta
roba
quando lasci che i tuoi amici facciano
una grigliata a pasqua succede questo
per questo aspetto c'è una porta
maledetta apri apri una tenda oddio oro
oro grazie a dio subito l'ho presa
figurazioni lascio scappare su
opportunità incredibile che specialità
da qualche tiro potrei fidarvi ha detto
se riuscissi a prete
trovo un gancio per sollevare il
cancello si chiama perché devo trovare
le cose in un posto dove non riesco
neanche a trovare le porte per trovare
dei ganci dio santo ma penso che ora
anche resti viva i mega di allora avevo
passato con la solita frigo allora dio
ma che frigo dall'apocalisse per pulire
il suo schifo scivolato che privo love
is the best place to find aggancio bari
smeraldo o ecologico o cazzo dici che
rotola sul ghiaccio trovato il gancio la
che ci ho messo una vita a questa roba
qua in teoria potresti anche darla in
bocca alla ti fa brutta o dalla mia
ampia esperienza horror
io adesso esco di qua e là ti va di in
groppa subito vero
bene
non mi è ancora ucciso che strano
ragazze non c'è il corpo sbatto il cazzo
ma guardi guardi non mi ha toccato laga
incredibile non ho capito dove foto e io
parlo grande fantastico veloce veloce
veloce bianca di veloce visto gancio
schifoso vai petto veloce gira veloce
quanto tempo
ok non ci passa lei è troppo grossa
[Applauso]
chiudi chiodi gary gray bear madonna
pure di calci in faccia ti faccio
diventare bella zia
guardali guardali la coscienza e melo
pupi tutto attraverso le sbarre qualche
cosa e chi si ferma i romani
grazie a quella è la miniera
ok ragazzo ha messo una vita ad arrivare
prima alla chiesa poi alla miniera se
non trovo mia moglie me ne vado lì giuro
tanto non messa incinta in teoria non
riesca a fare immensi che quindi sono
autorizzato a farlo
fa piacere che come ornamenti per la
casa e per il giardino piazzate croci o
comunque passare dalla porta era troppo
mainstream
no sono di nuovo nella scuola vi prego
jessica jessica si è impiccata alla fine
tecnica cioè io sto cercando due donne
la mia agenzia
tutto sto casino per chiara ma
[ __ ] e the name of jazz jazz prize
e lo spingi un po di xaver è
imperdonabile unforgivable adesso che su
questa cosa incredibile questa
rivelazione assurda che ne faccia che
comparse qualcos'altro sul muro a una
polo è comparsa una porta dal nulla va
ben bello quando entri in una stanza
completamente buia silenzio se siete
solo una noce rossa mi devo aspettare
satana si accendo la luce
no il che è già un traguardo perché ci
fanno c'era sì
exit fuck yeah
[ __ ] cosa che sa basta cos'è
no niente c'è una specie di fantasma che
lei mi tocca che mi fa il pa ti denuncio
curate stronzo
basta palparmi cos'è sta roba cos'è sta
roba ma che si è interrogato pesante zio
corre il gran grazie dell'accoglienza
splendida comprese fantastici polipo sei
tu e giusto esaltare solo emesso sono
l'idraulico che controlla le tubature
per mika metà lgi a ragazzi in pochi
coglieranno questa cosa però da piccolo
giocava un videogioco che è di
strisciare i condotti era uguale come
acer al polipo mi sembrava strano no
perché sto gioco tutto e siamo ritornati
alla solita vita di merda fantastico
qualcuno mi spiega come sono arrivato
qua me lo spiegate per favore come ho
fatto ad arrivare lì chi è che bisogna
come cosa sono queste transizioni cosa
succede mele sogno compì tutto questo
c'è ancora la miniera si è quella del
perfetto ma per il caldo e edgar nanana
nanna che sei stato bravo su prime che
atleta scene equilibri creai hai bevuto
zio dal fatto che passi da scuola alle
miniere abbandonate
se come si è bevuto
lerda e vabbè è di avere a fare
l'equilibrista che succede cazzi tuoi
zio incassati devo dire più di così
cioè io ho provato in tutti i modi
andare in st minieri è impossibile ocado
succedendo
che cazzo e gollum devo girare il
monitor perché non vedo bene oggi a
zitto zitto che se non ti beccano stato
sono capi sono caduto da un chilometro
salve
forse ho trovato un nemico molto più
brutto di quella col martello ragazzi ed
era difficile orca vacca che schifo per
lasciati cadere a perché sono qui sono
agganciato a un albero allora ho capito
già pensate pensate che culo su tutto
sto casino vabbè posto a zio
sa qual è la videocamera che in tutto
questo non si è rotta wow e averci culo
ragazzo
frate sede visitare lo fai a casa tua
ok non è allora non mi hai pagato ai mal
di pancia zio lo noti e passa tutto è
sexy mamma
ma che cazzo
tanto lo sapevo ragazzi si sa era era
ovvio è rotta prova va bene non fa
niente macchia vacca cos'era borglum
sempre gollum
ciao tesoro cioè non fa niente dai
andiamo avanti sticazzi però fare il
figo e niente ucciso riuscito scarti non
posso passare di qua perché mi sa che
alcune persone sono finite male va bene
fatto quattro sotto bello addentriamoci
sempre di piu nella merda tanto ormai ci
siamo da una vita nella merda quindi chi
se ne frega
vai zio tutto carico ti voglio tutto
bello carico
vai frate ti sei tutti noi maledizione è
quella di prima è la tipa col martello a
bella è appunto non stai messa male non
starai mica pisciando
no a ziano ci devo passare io in
quell'acqua fai cagare che merda ma ci
devo passare io li fai schifo mi chiamo
una gigante così ma non soltanto nei ter
grazie gentilissima meraviglioso mai
mangiare kebab
quando sei in gigante perché la
situazione potrebbe sfuggirgli di mano
pesantemente che faccio non volevo
sbirciare mentre kagari il problema è
che è successo mi fai ridere lo stanzone
che il fatto è che parlano
[Musica]
ma quante minchia siete pazzi anche le
scene fosse solo una posso entrare in
casa tua azienda
mi sembra un sacco invitante no più che
altro magari provo cose utili tipo tipo
una donna morta
ciao zia o ecco il rais vedere
importante che le batterie sono pieni i
corsi core giorni
salve no quello non si fa a me la paghi
tu la lavanderia grazie genti missioni
nerd ok grazie non vere la prossima
volta che l'effetto è questo
questa porta non si apre perfetto ma
così quasi sono anche contento frate c'è
mica una scorciatoia fantastico zio mi
dovresti aprire anche se mi fai schifo
mi dovresti fare una cortesia aprista
porta aprì la porta frate posso passare
il collo stesso passo di qua salve è
sparito non so per quale motivo salve a
posto devo entrare grazie l'altro un
punticino fa vj hem ancora pochi j
uno di loro a casa dove stiamo andando
la che non lo so mi butto giù scavalca
se la cava benissimo grazie che le
tracce di sangue mi consigliano cosa
fare mi strapperò agli occhi di
strizzerà fino a far uscire
meno male che non ho finito di leggere
con un'auto per una volta sono contento
di aver finito di leggere quanto a
sventare ok
meno male che non lo sfiduciato da una
sporgenza sarebbe stato peggio dove sia
finito sempre bello pigliarsi la
mazzetta ta sotto ai denti prima di
salire in vetta che sa di una montagna
fantastico
tu sei sempre bello io voglio che una
volta volevo raggiungere una miniera
quella della miniera cesena scordati
proprio ma chi lo aveva visto quello vai
vai vai corri corri non ho neanche visto
come penso come sommesso ma che è ma
cos'è sta roba
poi via piero zucca china mila veramente
penoso zio vai vai vai perfetto per
gestire un fracasso sempre rompere il
cazzo dei dove vado
vai vai vai paesi dove non ti fermare
vai dove sto andando rigamonti sono
porta entra niente pareva guardaroba
ideale bassa però quanto tempo fa ciao
sono una zona amica sono a scuola
i suoi poi gesto io quando fanno sti
cambiamenti la scuola ha posto di merda
non li capisco però non lo capisco c'è
il turno che fino ci giochiamo chiesa
piccola sta roba
ma no che bevo lo farei gameplay
se però devi stare casa
ciao zio devo seguirti zia per forza
perché sennò non finiamo più
credevate cantare cira come sta che
palle
sì sì sì e il tronco di un albero
lo so sono tornato davvero prima
fantastico bello quando mi fa queste
transizioni sono troppo contento se mi
rincoglioniscono più di prima ragazzi
sono appena arrivato potevate non
rompere le palle in meno della crisi
che bello che ciao zio 61 gnocco da
paura veramente e non sai fermamente
nella copertina del video ma neanche per
sbaglio ma che schifo
no no no dai che merda lo mangiare
frankowski ordinato il suo uscita è
domanda ma come il martello e chiodi ma
che aveva preso per gesù cristo ma
fermati ma perché stai facendo tv o
lasciami me fate schifo
bastardi haters barche chiamo toni f che
vi [ __ ] una mazzetta ta sotto i denti
che merita tutti nella merda no dai raga
non potete crocifisso fisico ma sapete
che ci figlio non lo rifiuto michelle e
io rifiuto la crocifissione
voglio i testimoni di geova
aver ammesso che mette proposte dice no
no no non puoi fare questa cosa non
potete crocifiggermi il mio vangelo
lasciato nello zaino insieme a libero di
matematica fisica da l'asia non puoi
pacifico miss match di ieri sei bello
però dai ti faccio i complimenti per la
bellezza
no dai ragazzi no no assoluto a farlo la
falla sono 3 camera la somma umana non
abbandonato perfetto accadrà ya basta ho
capito basta non fatevi queste scene che
poi mi chianche grosso spedito mi deve
far male parecchio
no no no con quella c blocco io ecco
brava meno sloga che mi stai
crocifiggendo che faccio il kit make mi
hanno crocifisso non è uno scherzo
finito male
ma che male ragazza michele l'altro mi
avevano staccato il pisello pensate voi
gesù gesù è un'esclamazione in questo
momento posso fare è neanche giusta
profana fumo sbagliata non grosso suv
bastardo 2017 anni dopo beh dai sempre
più comodo del letto che al f
no dai non me lo fa fare
quindi ragazzi il vino di altro termina
qui vi aspetta un lunedì per l'ultimo
episodio di auto che facciamo insieme in
live e ricordatevi dalle 16 in poi però
se i ragazzi servito è piaciuto al suo
documento è un mi piace anche i vari
social che come descrizione su se stessi
temi civili al prossimo video
[Musica]